imagine now Ike Baron holds Bobby Lee
and Jordan Peele a pilot it's it's is it
30 minutes uh I think we did a short
like it was like 20 minutes do you still
have it somewhere I could find it yeah
yeah I remember the the there was a
scene where we like went to go hit on
some girls at a bar yeah and we all like
dressed up and what outfits that we
thought made us look hot yeah and you
were wearing like jeans and a t-shirt I
was wearing a suit and Jordan was
dressed like Morpheus from The Matrix
yeah like a little glasses I remember
that I remember that ladies we'd like to
have
I remember that I remember that I
remember that yeah I also remember I
want to apologize we got in a fight we
did get enough fight but over what do
you remember it was a cigarette
remember I was you were smoking that the
house at the house yeah yeah can you be
respectful for once yeah yeah and I
remember going you know I mean [__] you
yeah I'm doing this for free
all true altar altar I'll show me the
lie yeah it's so ashamed I mean should
we try to sell it now during the strike
back door
yeah he would never yeah if Jordan's
like yeah I was uh I was gonna uh direct
Schindler's List too but um
I'll do the like Bobby Jordan uh pilot
again dust off the Morpheus leather yeah
yeah amazing but imagine now yeah I
would love to see it though I'll find
I'll see if I can find I would love to
do it yeah it was really fun so let's
let's plug some of the stuff what so
what do you have a new movie because you
because I follow stassen too oh my God
yeah what's it called it's called
maximum truth maximum Truth where is it
it's very funny folks it's on demand you
can order it on demand
um uh yeah do you know Dylan O'Brien you
know this kid is Dylan O'Brien he's one
of these guys who if you're like over 40
you're like I know that face and if
you're under 30 you're obsessed with him
oh wow
um uh we after one night when we were
shooting we went to this bar on Ventura
and it was just like a perfect like
distillation of our two fandoms we're
sitting down
and a waitress comes over she's probably
like 23.
and she sees Dylan and she like [__]
freezes and her knees start shaking and
she's like
and her friend comes over and she's like
are you okay she's like I just I just
have to I have to I have to talk to them
I have to talk to him and like came over
and she's like trembling and he's like
oh hey nice to meet you and like 10
minutes later this like 50 year old guy
is leaving with like his like 30 year
old girlfriend and he looks at me and
goes SNL and just walk
I get that all still today they mix it
up yeah I have different experiences
totally different totally different
people will still say to me sometimes
are you gonna audition for SNL and I'm
like I'm in my mid-40s I don't think oh
why didn't you do it what like you could
just sign up like yeah I was just like
well I did this one I'm ready to jump
over here now uh uh there it is yeah
maximum truth Seth Meyer said it's
depressing to see a poster now where I'm
the old guy
but this is a very funny movie yeah it's
very much in like uh set in the world of
like like we were talking about like
right wing grifters like people right
now who are like I need to make money
and the best way to do that is to kind
of try to get it from people who are
like obsessed with like righty politics
so very very uh stupid very funny it
looks really fun it's so it goes down
like a ice cold pop on a summer day yeah
yeah that's what I say it's funny I've
had to detach myself from the whole
political thing because it's just I
found myself getting obsessed and also
it would dictate how I would feel during
the day yeah so and there's a sense of
powerlessness so you just I just you
know
I just can't watch it anymore oh I
completely uh disconnected I just read
the important things I would say uh but
the good news is Trump is coming back
he is going to be the nominee for sure
for sure he could win
oh if there's even like a mild like
recession why now listen why are you
laughing
he could no no but are you are you are
you excited
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah you know he wants to do this he
does not RFK the other Kennedy his son